Should I,
should I do headphones?
It doesn't matter.
Yeah,
like headphones.
I kind of hate hearing myself that way.
Sound good.
Why did you hear yourself?
Do you try to pull this sucker up like
about a fist from your face?
Good to see you again,
man.
It's been a long time.
It has been.
What?
The guy like you.
It's always nice to see you're still
alive.
Do you remember best to get tired of
hearing shit like that?
Oh,
I don't care.
I mean,
do you get tired of the weirdness of
like interviewing with people and
they're like,
you know,
you know you could die.
Is this scary?
Yeah.
That's all right though.
I mean,
the thing.
Yeah,
it's funny.
A tournament,
the film we've been doing q and a's
every night.
You get the same questions from the
audience all the time and part of that
is tiring,
but then part of it like people ask some
questions because they're obvious
because everybody wants to know the same
things and I'm like,
I understand that one of the weirdest
parts of the film is when they're
showing all the guys who have died from
free soloing and they're actually.
They didn't all die free soloing.
Oh,
that's actually one of the.
That's probably the only thing that I
take slight issue with a film,
slightly hyperbolic [inaudible].
The two of them died base jumping and
one of them died rope jumping.
They were all were free solos,
which is kind of what the film is saying
that they're all free solis who have
died,
but they all died in the mountains doing
mountain related extreme activities,
you know,
that's.
That doesn't make the story is good.
That's like poetic license.
Yeah,
he got sneaky.
Well,
you know,
I mean they all were free solace,
but yeah,
that's not the same though.
Yeah,
no,
exactly.
I,
I preferred it.
The other way to look at it is the no
free solis has ever died doing anything.
Cutting edge.
That's my favorite statistic that I'm
like no free solos has ever died doing
hard solar.
Like basically free a few free solos
have died falling off at easy turn or
just falling off sort of routine or you
know,
I don't know,
just falling off the mountain,
but none of them have ever died while
doing something,
cutting edge.
Something that had never been done
before.
Something that was you hardcore.
Do you think that's because when you're
doing something that's a little bit
easier,
you relax.
I think that's probably part of it,
but also I think part of it is just a
numbers thing.
You spend so much time doing easy stuff
and so little time doing really hard
stuff that,
you know,
it's just statistics.
But um,
how much,
how important is it when,
when you were free soloing to have that
edge to be like really cognizant about
how intense this is?
Like if you got to calm to relaxed.
No,
I think that's.
I think that is kind of the concern for
sure.
And I,
I've noticed that in for myself anyway,
and I try not to do very much easy
soloing anymore because there is a
certain complacency that overtime,
you know,
you just do so much mileage on easy
terrain and then you're like,
this is so easy,
this is so easy.
And then you slip and you die.
Well,
you know,
fighters look at things that way too.
Like they at a certain point in their
life,
they don't want easy fights because they
need to get challenged,
otherwise they won't train properly.
And then they wind up losing to be.
Yeah,
you should take it seriously.
Yeah.
Well the difference between a fighter
say
when they're not trained in not in camp
and just their skill and what their body
can do without,
without going through a camp is probably
only like 70 percent of what they are
when they actually go through everything
with full intensity,
eight weeks,
two times a day,
you know,
physical therapy,
massage,
visualization,
conditioning,
all the,
all the things that make them who they
are the day they step into the cage.
Like when you free Solo.
It's funny that,
so that's,
yeah,
I mean if you saw the film and that's
all a exactly the level of preparation
that went into it.
Do you take time off before a big free
solo?
Do you like,
you just kind of the opposite.
It's the.
No,
it's the opposite.
It's sort of ramping up to it.
Right.
But do you,
is there any concern that maybe you
haven't given yourself enough
recuperative time like that for the day
of.
No,
so for me anyway,
it was always sort of the opposite
because the real challenge of free
soloing is the psychological side of the
mental side of it.
It's not so much the physical,
like I don't necessarily have to
physically perform at the absolute limit
of what I'm capable of,
but I have to mentally perform at that
level.
And so,
and the mental side of it comes so much
from confidence and feeling,
you know,
feeling prepared.
And so I don't know.
So when I,
when I freestyle it all cap,
I kind of knew that I wasn't actually,
um,
like I'd probably already started to
decline a little bit physically over the
course of the season because the two
months in the seventies just kind of
grueling on her body,
like it all the time I spent going up
and down on the wall and preparing.
It's very,
very tiring.
And so I kind of realized that I was
starting to get sort of deeply fatigued.
I was sort of a week away from having
started a slump,
a black girl.
I'm Kinda pooped.
But the thing is I knew that that
because of all that preparation,
you know,
psychologically I was as,
as good as I was ever going to be.
So even if I was physically starting to
be a little bit tired,
it's like time to,
you know,
it's kind of the different curves.
You have to hit it right at the right
moment.
No.
Is your psychological preparation just
you getting your mind into it or do you
have like specific techniques you use or
a form of meditation or anything that
you specifically concentrate on?
When you're visualizing success or
no,
when it's not even necessarily
visualizing success or it's visualizing,
for me it's visualizing the experience,
like sort of imagining what everything
will feel like imagining what it would
like to place my foot on a hold or what,
you know,
grabbing like the sensations of it and
the exposure of it.
Um,
you know,
thinking through what it'll feel like
with so much air around me and no rope.
Just that basically to make sure that
nothing is surprising when I get there
to my hands are sweating.
Just talking to you.
I'm not kidding.
Feel that,
feel that.
That's fucking gross.
Right?
As a clam.
I realized it like when I'm talking to
you,
I'm thinking about you doing this and my
hands started sweating.
You start thinking about thousands of a
or in your life.
Start thinking about chalk and powder
and that shit like that.
God Damn Dude.
Have you ever gone to like a sports
psychologist
or have you ever actively tried to
coordinate a program for mental training
or anything like that?
No,
not really.
I mean,
so with,
with reselling ocap I found that I
needed to create enough space for,
it's not so much mental training but um,
but create enough empty time so that I
had a so that I was able to sort of
process so,
um,
I don't know,
so I like stopped shooting an email.
I raised my social media,
like sort of freedom my life and then
actually my girlfriend left for the sort
of the week ahead of time,
so that was just totally by myself and
my van with nothing going on,
like no distractions.
And so that's not exactly,
you know,
mental training,
but it was giving myself the free time
that I could just sit around and think
about things,
you know,
I can process it in my own terms in my
own time.
When was the last time we talked?
How many years ago?
It was so long.
I feel like it was at least for right?
Oh No,
it was like six or seven.
It wasn't I think so.
I think it was like 2012 or something.
During that time.
How much has changed in your life in
terms of the way people perceive what
you do and the amount of attention that
you get?
I would imagine that having that alone
time now you as much harder.
Yeah.
No,
totally.
It's,
it's funny.
I mean I've tried to not let my life get
busy over time,
but it just sort of naturally happens.
I mean,
what would success?
Yeah,
exactly.
Just some one more times.
I'll be.
When I was reached out to you,
I reached out to you a couple of times,
but I was like,
this guy is probably getting fucked with
all the time.
Like someone's probably always poking at
you and you're just trying to get a
foothold.
Like literally just trying to hold on.
No,
I mean,
no,
I mean I,
I appreciate all the opportunities that
have now and you know,
I mean I'm,
I'm very happy with the way my life has
changed over time,
but certainly when I look back at 10 or
12 years ago when I was just a single 20
year old man living in a car,
like I had nothing going on.
You know,
if,
uh,
if I had like one interview in a month,
I'd be like,
well,
it's a big month for media,
you know,
and then now on the film tour,
it's like completely outrageous.
It's totally the other end of the
spectrum.
Now when you do in this film to uh,
when,
when does the film actually come out?
Films like out.
It's in theaters.
So I couldn't go see right now.
But you can't get it on itunes yet.
Is that what it is?
So yeah.
So,
so it did a month of festival circuit
in,
you know,
earlier in the end of the summer and
then it came out in theaters at the end
of September.
So right now I think this weekend is its
widest release.
It's like 400 theaters all over the
country are now.
Wow.
But,
and then in theory,
um,
it's through national geographic,
so I think it'll be on television,
on the channel at some point and then
eventually it'll stream somewhere.
I Dunno.
Is it strange all this attention?
Yeah,
I mean,
well,
I don't know.
It's in some ways it's a natural
extension of all the stuff I've had over
the years,
you know,
like having a 60 minutes piece and many
years ago was a bit of a,
it was a flurry of attention and so
they're kind of sort of prepared me in
some ways,
you know.
But yeah,
I mean,
and well,
you've dealt with this your whole life.
I mean it's.
Yeah,
but I'm asking like an interesting.
Yeah.
But I feel like it comes with what I do.
I'm in show business.
That's,
you know what I mean?
That's fair.
You're,
you're a climber.
Yeah.
And the most radical kind of climber
free solo you think when I think of what
you do,
I think of quiet tension.
Yeah.
That's,
that's kind of fair.
Yeah.
Because it should be,
it should be sort of meditative and
relaxing and quiet,
but then obviously you're also sometimes
straining your entire body,
you know,
like trying very hard physically and.
Yeah.
Well I remember one of the things you
said to me the last time we talked was
that it's,
it's very mellow because if it ever gets
intense,
something's gone wrong.
Yeah,
no,
I still feel exactly the same way.
I mean that's,
yeah,
that's always the challenge is to keep
it,
keep it relaxed,
but for a guy like you,
my perception of a guy like you,
who's that?
That person who's doing that activity
than to sort of juxtapose that with this
media tour type environment and dealing
with all these people that,
that,
that seems to me like it would be really
annoying.
I mean,
yeah,
it's very different than my normal
normal lifestyle I guess.
But the thing is,
you know,
it's sort of an adventure and it's an
experience in its own way.
I've been,
I've been kind of calling it a
expedition film tour because a,
I've done a lot of expeditions in my
life.
Like last winter I went to Antarctica
for a month and,
and it's not exactly the type of climate
that normally do and I don't really like
being cold,
but you sort of like,
oh it a once in a lifetime opportunity
to go somewhere,
you know,
it was like going to Mars or something.
It was this totally outrageous
experience.
We're climbing big rock walls and in an
article you're just living on the
glacier and it's totally different.
Totally crazy.
He camped out on a glacier.
Yeah.
We're just in a tent on a glacier for a
month.
When you do that,
how thick a pad do you use?
A really thick and a very,
very thick sleeping bag.
Do you ever get warm?
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
In Your Sleep Med.
It's a negative 40 degree sleeping bag.
I mean,
it's pretty good job but.
But anyway,
I mean,
so that kind of experience,
you know,
in some ways it's very comparable to a
film to where I'm like,
this is going to be a once in a lifetime
thing.
You just embrace it.
You go with it,
you know,
it's different than the way you normally
choose to live your life,
but that kind of makes it understanding,
you know,
it's something new.
Well,
I can imagine it would be very
interesting.
The Antarctica thing sounds like a trip.
Yeah.
Like were you traveling on uh,
uh,
established corridor?
It was.
No,
no.
It's what.
So some people had climbed in the region
before,
but um,
but we actually did tons of first
ascents like roots and summits that had
never been climbed.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Now when you do something like that,
do you map it out in advance?
Like,
I mean,
well,
not really because I mean they're photos
of,
of the formations and people,
like I said,
it climbed some of them.
Um,
some Norwegians had sort of pioneered
the area and written a book about it,
but um,
but then it's not until you get there
that you can really decide what you're
going to climb and how it looks.
I mean ultimately you have to look at
the rock and see if it's climate
bowling,
so you basically just have to ski up and
then touch it and see what you can do
and then try to climate you ski up where
you are because you're living on a
glacier.
I mean you have to ski everyone.
Wow.
It was cool.
I did a,
I did a month wearing only ski boots or
climate shoes.
Wow.
Or,
or my bedroom slippers are on camp.
What'd you feet feel like?
Oh No,
we're in a really thick socks and then
keeping everything as warm as possible,
but,
but yeah,
I mean we're in climate.
Jews in Antarctica goes pretty chilly.
Yeah.
Actually there's a film about that
coming out in a couple of weeks I think
as part of the real rocky or it's like a
big climbing film festival thing or film
tour that sort of shows around the
world.
But.
So it's like a 40 minute short.
They're 30 minutes short.
I'm actually,
I haven't seen it yet,
but those shoes that you wear on a
normal climb are very flexible with
those last sportiva yeah,
that's what I said.
Our,
yeah,
they're very,
they almost look like a sock with a
rubber bottom to it where you could
really kind of grip.
It depends.
So some are super soft like that.
Um,
it depends on what you're trying to
climb that summer.
Really rigid so that you can step on a
really small holes and it supports your
foot.
So like what I was wearing,
free soloing El cap is quite rigid
actually.
It's like a board,
like a platform.
So that you can put just the tip of your
toe on something really small and you're
focused to stay,
stay flat,
welcome mountaineering type of.
Yeah,
kind of,
but still also very precise because
mountaineering boot,
you think clunky and big climbing shoes,
like a ballet slipper,
like precise and tight.
But then also rigid sometimes.
Yeah.
And then also,
I don't know,
you know,
when you're climbing cracks,
you put your foot into the crack and
then torque it sideways to like lock it
into place.
And so the stiffer the shoe is,
the more it can,
you know,
the more that you can lock the shoe into
place,
it's pose your foot.
You basically have to use fewer muscles.
I,
when are you starting a trend?
Are there other people that are
following you footsteps now?
Actually,
what do you think?
I think probably.
Yeah.
You think,
yeah,
you honestly think though.
Yeah,
I think there's probably some people
that look at what you're doing and the
young kids that think it must be,
you know,
here's what I think most people look at
the path that the average person takes
in life,
you know?
Oh No,
sell cars,
I'm going to be an insurance guy,
and they look,
they look at it like it's death for.
They look at a kid,
a young kid who's like enjoying playing
with his friends or doing sports or
playing video games or reading comic
books and then you look at what could be
the average path that the average person
takes in life and sitting in an office
all day under fluorescent lights and it
looks like death.
It looks like a slow aching death,
but then I look at someone like you.
I'm like,
wow,
this guy is living a special life.
This is a special life was so ideally
though somebody would look at it and see
that this is somebody living a very
intentional life or having chosen a
certain path,
not necessarily free selling.
I mean I would love to inspire people to
live an intentional life that they care
about.
I don't necessarily feel like people
need to go free solar.
Right.
Well I think that's.
That's a very good way of describing it.
Very good way of putting.
Because I think you most
certainly have influenced people in that
regard,
but I think also people must be
influenced in the sense that they see
where you're doing is man,
there's moments that you must experience
while you are climbing these incredible
faces that are kind of magical.
When you're up there,
you're a thousand feet up there.
The view is fucking spectacular and
you're doing it and you get to the top
of these things though the rush and the
feeling of accomplishment and the
euphoria and just the glory of nature
from the perspective yet,
or like,
look at this.
You could fucking wash your clothes on
the sweat.
That's in my hands right now,
man.
That's a stat.
Fucking pictures insane.
We're looking at,
what is the name of this photo,
Jamie?
It's a endura corner from cap.
That's actually,
that's a movie poster.
Do Fuck.
That man
is so,
so that,
that that is not sitting in a cubicle.
That is
not fluorescent light.
That is the end of a very long path that
you have to choose and really cultivate.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's for me,
23 years of sort of going into or 22
years or something of going down a very
specific path.
Very specific,
you know.
And you're still.
Do you have a different van?
Are you still in the same van?
I'm in a better man.
The last time I was here.
Moving on.
Yeah,
moved up.
It was pretty exciting.
And to have a house now that's actually
a real person.
I live in La.
I live in Las Vegas now.
Do you realize?
Yeah.
Why Las Vegas?
Uh,
do the best,
best four season climate in the country.
We Love Las Vegas.
Yeah,
there's climbing everywhere and it's
super accessible and it's easy and it's
cheap.
Cost of living easy.
You no traffic like everything is easy,
but I love Vegas.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Um,
whenever I go to Vegas I was looking at
the mountains outside of it and they're
right there and nobody even looks at
them from my driveway.
You can see 2000 foot walls.
I mean you,
you can be climbing on a 2000 foot long,
25 minute drive,
20 minute drive.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
A lot of people like to run those
mountains to run those hills.
There's a lot of trail runners that live
in that area as well.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
The west side of town and you're like in
the mountains.
I mean,
I can go mountain biking.
I can go hiking,
I can go climbing on 20 minutes.
You Vegas is kind of a misunderstood
place really is.
Everyone just thinks the strip,
but it's like it's not really the strip.
It's like the mountains all around it,
but biggest is like in a bowl of
mountains.
I mean all sides of it are surrounded by
Will Nevada in general kind of gets
weird because.
Yeah,
I know people think of the desert in
Nevada,
but really it's mountains.
I mean it's like series of mountain
ranges all the way across the state.
Yeah,
it really is.
I have a buddy who lives in Reno.
He lives outside of Reno and if you went
near where he lives,
he'd be like,
where are we?
Call Rato.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
No,
I'm in Tahoe,
like talk was right there and yeah,
in truckee donner,
I mean there's a bunch of commentary is
right there.
They're great and freaking skiing all
winter.
It's pretty cool.
How old,
you know,
I'm a 33.
Do you feel
any difference in the way your body
responds to doing this on a regular
basis now?
Maybe a little bit.
Um,
I'm,
I hate to say I'm getting old and
everything but uh,
but I think especially right now with
the film to her,
the amount of travel,
I'm like,
I'm more intentional about my diet and
stuff now and trying to get enough sleep
and things like that.
So in the,
you know,
10 years ago I could just eat a whole
tray oreos and be like,
all right,
I feel great.
Let's go climb in the gym.
It'll be fun,
you know,
now I'm like,
Oh man,
I want my green smoothie,
I want to get my night's sleep.
And Yeah,
I saw that you're,
you're not eating meat anymore.
And then you eat a lot of vegetables and
do you get your blood work done or do
you do work with nutritionists?
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Good.
Um,
yeah,
and I mean I don't have cheese and stuff
and I mean even meat.
So I mean I gave up eating meat for
environmental reasons mostly,
um,
like basically impact on the earth and
so I'm not fundamentally pose,
you know,
like I'll eat meat from time to time
certainly for,
for cultural norms.
Like uh,
you know,
I was in Japan earlier this year and I'm
sorry fish,
they're a bit just because I felt like
it was part of the sort of Japanese
travel experience.
Um,
if someone hunted it,
would you eat it?
Yeah,
yeah,
sometimes.
But the thing is I just don't feel like
I need to intentionally kill another
creature for me to survive.
And so if somebody was going to go
hunting for me to eat,
I'd be like,
no,
that's fine.
We're going to need that.
But then I'm like,
on an expedition to Antarctica,
I ate a bunch of random meat just
because it's like,
it's already there,
you know,
the other team members have already
brought it.
I'm sort of like,
well,
I'm hungry or whatever,
you know.
Um,
mollusks are actually a good thing for
people to look into that are Vegan or
vegetarian and they don't want to eat
meat because they're actually more
primitive even than vegetables.
They're not like,
like,
um,
clams and scallops.
They're incredibly primitive.
They,
they have no feelings.
They don't feel anything.
They have no that there's an argument
that could be made that plants
communicate far more than mollusks
lobster,
oysters rather mussels.
Barnacles.
Yeah,
crunchy.
But there's a protein to them that's
similar to an animal protein,
but incredibly primitive to what I mean,
insect protein.
I think it's sort of a potential future
of humanity today.
Um,
yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not fundamentally opposed to eating
insects,
but it's just,
you know,
they're rarely served.
But I would just imagine that
particularly as you get older,
like nutrition would be a major factor.
Making sure you get the proper amount of
essential fatty acids and making sure
that because your brain must be like you
have to fuel your brain in terms of like
giving your brain the building blocks
for neurotransmitters and all these
different things that you're.
You're using when you're.
You've got this intense concentration
for many,
many hours at a time and you're not
eating when you're doing these things.
Sometimes you do stop and you eat
something.
I mean you have to.
I mean if you're criminal or something
like flowers,
sometimes little bars or nut butter.
Fairmount are.
Yeah,
those f bombs.
Do you ever take those that has that?
Oh,
they're great.
I have a whole box of them will give you
some.
They them,
yeah.
It's called a [inaudible].
It's called F bomb,
like fat bomb,
but it's all like nut butter and oils
and it comes in a packet.
You just ripped the top of the package
off and squeeze it in your mouth.
I had three x morning.
Oh Wow.
That's really good.
It's really healthy.
If one sitting around,
I'm curious.
I want to do have them in the back.
I finished it.
Um,
yes.
That is it.
Tell Jeff there's a box of them in my
office over there.
You know where the boxes just go.
You can go run in and grab them.
Go run into that door,
run into the office door and like
sitting right in the front to the right
hand side.
There's a box of them.
I'll give you that.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
The know butterflies.
I eat the shit out of those things.
I eat like three or four of them in the
morning when I'm headed out the door
with a cup of coffee.
Like a lot of,
a lot of that though.
It was just a lot of calories at there.
I'm doing this sober October fitness
challenge with my friends.
I've been working out.
I'm not now no bullshit as much as five
hours in a day because I'm trying to win
this.
We have a wwe style championship belts.
It says intercontinental champion.
So rocktober or intergalactic champions.
So the sober part though,
does that mean you're not?
No Pot,
no booze,
no nothing.
Oh yeah.
Here's your just clean living for all of
October and training.
Fricken brainer.
Yeah.
Well we were wearing these,
uh,
these belts that measure your heart rate
and they also quantify your performance,
like how much calories you've burned.
And there it is.
He could take that.
That's tufts to shit.
What flavors?
That one,
um,
academia pecan with Cecil.
Fantastic stuff.
I liked the chocolate and sea salt one
too.
I'll look through in a sample of players
are good.
That's cool.
It's a real healthy.
It's,
you know,
just watch it.
It's really what you need.
You actually list ingredients or.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it seems awesome.
And you just tear,
you smush them up and you tear the top
and just squirt it in your mouth.
Yeah,
I do that climbing a lot.
I kind of prefer that to,
to um,
you know,
gels or Goo or whatever you want to call
it because that's just pure sugar.
I kind of prefer to have pure fat.
Yeah.
Certainly for climbing,
um,
it's just not like in,
it's not like running or cycling or
something where your engine is burning
nonstop where you kind of need to just
like pumps sugar into it.
It's kind of a longer slow burn.
You can,
you can eat fat for sure.
Do you ever,
um,
mess around with nootropics at all?
I've never even heard that word.
Nootropics are,
are the building blocks for human
neurotransmitters.
It's like they're there.
Their supplements that enhanced
cognitive function is,
some of them are like standard,
what you'd get at like Gnc you wouldn't
think of as a nootropic,
but they're finding out they are
like creatine.
They're finding out creatine is actually
a pretty potent nootropic.
It actually enhances cognitive
performance.
But,
um,
there's one called Alpha brain that my
company has.
I'll send a bunch of it to you.
There's another company called neuro one
that makes a great one.
You know,
Bill,
Roman [inaudible] is a former NFL player
who,
uh,
you know,
took a lot of patriots.
No,
it mostly on the broncos.
Yeah.
Savage,
crazy animals.
And during his day,
you know,
obviously sustained a lot of head
injuries and wanted to find some sort of
a natural way to replenish his brain
function.
So He created this company called neuro
one and that's.
This is how I found out about nootropics
is through his,
his product.
It's fantastic.
Great stuff.
It's just powder.
You put it in water,
shake it up.
It actually has a protein and a bunch of
different neurotransmitters in it,
but it's really good for enhancing
function.
Interesting.
I wonder if it actually works.
Yeah,
it does.
Well,
Alpha brain,
my company,
we had two double blind placebo
controlled studies with the Boston
Center for memory that showed
improvements in verbal memory and
reaction time in peak alpha flow state.
So what is peak out propose to?
That's a good question.
You have to start to dive into it.
Yeah,
they're all the.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com,
all of the tests are available.
You can go over what it means,
but what,
what you find from these.
Another one called true brain that.
What is that guy's name?
That when he was a guest to the podcast,
Dr Andrew.
No,
that's Andy Galpin.
There's my point is besides my company
does a bunch of companies and make a
really good ones and they are fantastic.
If you have to give speeches or have you
talked to one of the things that I do
like
commentary,
straight cocaine,
you,
you're all fired up and you just give a
great talk or anything.
You're like,
methamphetamines,
you just get all fired up.
That's a question I had for you too.
Like how many people that are doing what
you do are on either adderall or they
take things like Beta blockers,
that sort of.
Honestly I think nobody but I mean a lot
of climbers smoke a lot of weed or you
know,
and nowadays I don't even know what you
do with it because you don't even have
to smoke.
Just you drink it and stuff.
I don't know.
There's so many like cannabis things
now,
but um,
but no,
I don't know.
So I,
I've never really done drugs.
I don't,
I'm not totally interested center,
they know anything about it.
But um,
I don't know.
It's interesting because it's not like
anyone's drug testing climbers and
unless they're competing in the world
cup level or it's actually gonna be in
the Olympics in 2020,
but yeah,
climbing goes,
it's like a demonstration.
So did they have um,
an event like in terms of like a pathway
that you have to go through?
So it's um,
what's a world cup climbing breaks into
three disciplines like lead climbing,
which is like a same as the indoor wall
and then bouldering,
which is without a rope,
you know,
you just climbed 12 feet or whatever.
And then speed climbing where it's like
a preset course.
Everyone does the exact same course
where you just go as fast as you can and
just against the time.
And so normally those are three
disciplines for the World Cup,
but the Olympic format combines all
three into one competition because
they're limited by how many metals and
whatever,
because it's like a demonstration sport.
They're just sort of,
you know,
it's smaller scale than,
than some of the other sports in the
Olympics.
But.
So,
um,
yeah,
so basically common competitors just
have to do all three disciplines.
And See who wins.
I was watching something on youtube
where they had this climbing competition
more.
They like ready,
set,
go.
And then they like shot up.
That's the speed coming.
And this lady who's wearing a burka,
she,
she like famous or something.
No,
I don't know.
But um,
but there are a bunch of really strong
Iranian speed climbers and so I wouldn't
be surprised if,
if,
uh,
it's part of that,
ah,
she ran up at like a spider was crazy to
watch yet for whatever reason,
speak something is really big in eastern
Europe.
And then there are a couple of really
good Iranian speed commerce and um,
yeah,
they're just,
it's like it's sort of,
it's own little niche sport coming out
of certain parts of the world that is.
Well there's some strong genes over
there and around like a lot of great
wrestlers because,
I dunno,
I dunno if the woman you're talking
about is from there.
I'm thinking of one specific dude who's
so much his portrait in speed,
Iranian Foreign Nas.
Spell that as my.
Is I there?
I think you've pretty much got that.
Yeah.
What I want to see the video that I want
to see you find the video of her because
she's a fucking spider man.
Runs up the side of that hill.
He's going to browse the Internet.
Yes.
He could find her anyway.
But so with the,
uh,
with the new Olympic style climate,
I mean,
obviously there'll be drug tested with
world cup is drug testing,
but it's funny with the.
But nobody really uses performance
enhancing drugs.
I don't think they have legs one.
Fear enough.
I'm good.
Thank you.
One a one world cup climber had a metal
taken away for having used a
recreational cocaine.
And he was like,
Oh,
I'm really sorry.
Uh,
you know,
I'm sorry I did coke.
But he was like,
it was more for the partying and the
performance,
you know,
she is.
Look at her place.
I mean,
for a guy like you,
is that impressive?
Like what?
See that play that from the beginning,
does it?
That's,
that's pretty fast.
That's not as fast.
I mean,
if you watch some of the more lead
times,
it's,
it's faster for sure.
Um,
women or men?
Both,
I think.
I don't think that's true in that.
I think so.
I don't know.
Wow.
I don't know man.
Well,
you're,
you're the guy who would know to me.
That's damn impressive.
Just look up a world record.
I mean,
I think the male record is like five
point seven seconds,
six seconds.
It's like something really,
really fast.
Now.
Do they know this path in advance?
Yeah.
So that's exactly the same route for
everybody.
Always same distance,
same holds.
Um,
and so you basically memorize the
sequence and then you just perform it as
fast as you can.
So here we go.
Here's the world record as this.
So you stand on that thing and the timer
starts when your one foot comes off the
timer on the ground and then it ends.
When you slap the thing on the top.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Look at that five point.
Whatever seconds.
Oh my God.
That doesn't look real.
It doesn't look like he's just running
on the sidewalk.
Just tilted the camera and they're,
they're faking it.
Yeah.
For the camera.
No,
it's totally.
Now,
do these guys free solo or they,
they specifically concentrate on.
Imagine if you were free,
so like,
like this,
you would die for sure.
Know that Beta blockers would be
something that someone who free Solos
would want to look into.
I don't even know yet.
I don't know that it was Beta blockers
or something that blocks your,
your brain's production of adrenaline.
Oh,
but I mean,
I don't know if you'd want that though,
because the thing is if you have an
adrenaline spike it's because something
weird went on and you probably want to.
Like I've had A.
I've had a couple times where I broke a
hold off or something.
Like all of a sudden your whole drips
off and then you have that like
superhuman surgery and you grabbed back
on.
Yeah.
You don't want to be mellow at that
time.
Yeah,
exactly.
You don't want to be like,
I'm so relaxed as I fall all the way to
the valley floor.
You know?
It's like you want to fricking hold on.
One of the things in the film was one of
the guys who fell and I guess eventually
died.
He was doing it.
He fell and base jumped.
Yeah.
With a parachute.
He called it freebasing.
He sort of pioneered the sport as a
word,
but they're usually a good thing to have
on your back.
Well,
not really.
So yeah,
I mean the idea makes sense that if
you're going to fall off a cliff,
have a parachute.
The thing is that you need to be on a
very specific kind of cliff,
like what he was on,
where it was overhanging so that when he
fell he cleared the wall and he floated
out into space.
But the thing is when you send money,
all the walls are slightly less than
vertical in general.
And so it means that you just tumbled
down the wall,
you know?
And the other thing is that even if you
have a parachute,
parachutes function as a.
When you have a direction to them,
like Eric comes into them and you fly in
a direction which means that you have to
be facing away from the wall.
When you opened your parachute or else
you just fly right into the wall and
crash.
Yeah.
So it basically means that if you fall
off unexpectedly,
you then have to track away from the
wall.
Write yourself in mid air,
you know,
correct for everything and then make
sure you're facing the right way.
And he was like,
basically there's a lot of things that
have to go right for the parachute to
help you.
But no,
that's not good.
Yeah,
I mean it's one of,
a lot of people ask that.
They're like,
oh,
why don't you wear a parachute?
And you're like,
well it's basically this 10 pound
training weight that doesn't really help
you much with that guy.
Just jumped on purpose.
Yeah,
this is.
Oh,
well,
yeah.
So it's good.
So this is on the Uyghur though,
it looks like,
I think.
Um,
and you can.
Yeah.
So he's like jumping away.
He's getting a nice controlled opening.
He's like flying away from the cliff.
It's like everything is going right for
them.
But imagine if one of his foot holes
just broke and he started pinwheel and
down the wall it's like you'd never get
the separation from the wall.
Disaster like was just watch extreme
sports videos and I'll just commentate
on them because were like all,
well this guy is surely going to have a
disaster.
Well,
one of the things from the video when
they were talking about all the people
that have died,
that every,
essentially everyone from the past that
was a free solar is dead and you're
saying there's other things that they
were doing,
like base jumping,
like base jumping and,
and,
and even,
there are a couple of older soloists,
I mean in the film,
uh,
Peter Croft,
who's like a legendary soloist and he
was a childhood hero of mine and he's,
you know,
I don't want to say pushing 66.
I'm not sure how old Peter is,
but he's,
you know,
he's an older,
he's a distinguished gentleman and he's
uh,
he's living in the eastern Sierra.
He's climbing all the time.
He's like loving life with his wife and
actually he's in Greece on a sport
climbing vacation right now.
I'm just climbing for two months,
just fun climbing with a rope,
having a great time.
And so,
you know,
I look at somebody like Peter and he,
he was free soloing at,
at the very cutting edge for 20 years
basically.
And it's still just a happy climate now,
but does he free solo anymore?
It just climbs well.
So it's funny.
I had dinner with him a couple of years
ago and I was like,
oh Peter,
at what point did you quit soloing at
sort of an elite level,
you know,
like when did you sort of back off the
grids?
And he was like,
well actually I did want to technically
by the numbers I did one of my hardest
free solos couple of years ago.
Um,
but it was like a sport route at his
local Craig.
So like a route that he routinely climb
for fitness.
They just happened to be a pretty hard
number,
you know,
like climate grades are all sorted,
categorized.
And so you use like.
Yeah,
technically one of my hardest solos.
It was just recently,
but it's like a hard number but not
nearly as much of an undertaking as some
of the big solos that he'd done in the
past.
Like some of the walls that he had at
any 70 back in the day,
you know.
And so he was like,
oh,
it's all just kind of how you define
difficulty,
you know.
Now when,
when you say that there's a number
system that sort of rates what,
like how difficult a free Solo Path is?
Well,
no,
the rates climbing in general with a
rope or without a rope is just,
it just rates how hard our climate is.
What is El Cap was?
So the route that I climbed is 5:12
d for whatever that means,
or maybe it's 13,
eight depending on how you,
depending on what you want to call it.
But um,
what does that mean?
Yeah,
exactly.
So the climbing,
climbing grades are defined,
I don't know.
So in America it's by the,
you many decimal system and it's a
classification of terrain from one to
one to six decibels decimal decimal
system,
you know?
Yes.
But it's,
it's other parts of the world have
different systems.
And like I'm in Australia is just an
open ended numbers from one to 38 or
something.
Whereas they get progressively harder.
Oh,
there it is right here,
right there.
Yeah.
Climbing grade comparison.
Oh,
that's interesting to one.
They all do it differently.
It was because climbing culture grew up
in all different parts of the world.
Right.
And climbing culture I guess is a big
part of Yosemite yet.
Well,
yeah.
I mean climbing as a sport in the US is
sort of birthed from you somebody,
I mean the history of albinism or
climate rock climbing anyway.
Certainly comes from you.
Somebody in the US.
Is it just because the paths are so cool
that it just drew people to it or.
Yeah,
partially.
I mean,
yeah,
the summits are so striking and I think
a lot of it also just had to do with,
um,
just culture because a big part of it
was people from La and the bay area who
probably had some sense of classical
albinism from the Alps,
you know,
people who have traveled to some extent
and then wanted to climb other mountains
and then they happen to live near one of
the most iconic areas in the world.
And so then,
I don't know.
But anyway,
so it winds up being called the
ascending decimal system.
But um,
but yeah,
so basically it's the,
the,
it's categories of terrain,
so one being walking on a normal trail
to being like scrambling a little bit,
three being like scrambling with your
hands and feet up,
you know,
rocks and then fourth class being like
sorta like climbing but easier and then
fifth class being actual rock climbing.
And so then it was five point one
through nine depending on how hard
things are,
you know,
so five point,
one being pretty easy,
five point nine being pretty hard,
like you're rock climbing now and
technical and then at a certain point
that system wasn't adequate so they had
to start adding,
you know,
fivepoint 10 and then they subdivided
into Abcd and then five point 11 abcd
and the five point 12.
And so now it's an open ended system
that right now goes up to five slash 16
basically.
Whoa.
El Cap is really complicated.
Yeah.
But so el Cap is 12 d or five point 12 d
or maybe five point 13 eight,
which is the next grade up.
Um,
it's all sorted,
but,
so basically that means that it's,
it's elite.
Like that's very difficult and something
that like a,
obviously an average person can do,
but it's definitely not close to the
physical limit of what's been done in
the world.
Uh,
but that's with a rope on and that's
after you know,
years of practice and what's the
physical limit,
like what is the peak of where right now
the hardest grade in the world is 15 d,
which is extremely hard.
I mean,
it's totally crazy,
but so one guy,
this guy has done one route that he
called 15 d and so it hasn't been
repeated so it's not like an established
consensus,
but there are several 15 seas in the
world and there are many 15 bees in the
world.
Whereas this 15 d,
it's in a cave in Norway.
I mean it's,
um,
yeah,
that's the kind of the interesting thing
about climbing grades and climbing
difficulties that they're all spread
around the world,
the very specific clips because it
requires just the right combination of,
of angle and holds,
you know,
there have to be enough things to hold
onto,
but not too many else.
It's easier.
And so I for an elite climber and
they're basically searching the world
all the time,
trying to find that right mixture of,
of rock.
Wow.
What a strange existence.
It's really,
really nice.
Yachts forgot.
Unusual now when you hear about it,
but it's also kind of elemental in a
way,
you know,
because rocks are just out there and
you're basically just going and
exploring nature until you find the
right kind of challenge.
What?
Yeah.
There's.
Got It.
There's some sort of a primal
satisfaction that comes from climbing
something,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
There's a certain.
Yeah,
there's an elemental quality for sure.
Where you're like,
this is something that just exists in
the world.
And you just say you have this,
this,
this is Adam,
Andrea,
this check kid climbing,
15 odd commander coming out about it,
I guess.
No,
it's already out.
It's,
it's a short online actually.
Silence.
Yeah.
The route he put up,
he called silence.
But uh,
if this is the film,
just scrub all the way to the.
Oh,
that's the.
Yeah.
So you can see he's climbing feet first
through some of it and it's totally
extreme.
It's so this Guy Adam,
Andrea is,
is for sure the strongest climber in the
world right now.
Like physical?
Yeah.
Physically.
So He's,
he put up the world's first 15 c and the
first 15 d,
so he's basically push the edge of
difficulty for the last several grades
and he's just freakishly strong.
Is that something that you would have to
be to do what he's doing?
Like A,
a regular climber?
Couldn't do what he's doing is almost
like acrobatic involved.
Yeah,
we look at what he's doing right there.
It's like,
oh,
that's.
So this is the world's first 15.
See?
So slightly easier.
He did this several years ago,
but it's like,
um,
and then here I'm like,
yeah,
but that's where he has a rope,
you know,
and you trust that over and over and
over.
But yeah,
he's,
he's an amazing climber.
He's really,
he's like a polymath.
He's like,
he's graded every discipline.
What else does he do?
Well,
so he.
Have you heard at the dawn wall on Ocap?
No,
I'm so Tommy Caldwell.
You know who he is.
Another professional climber.
Um,
he's,
he was,
I don't know.
Yeah,
he's basically one of America's best
climbers.
He did this route called the dawn wall,
um,
which is also a film in theaters or
wasn't theaters last month is sort of
random that to big con and films came
out exactly the same time,
but it was just one of those freak
things.
But so the dawn wall was considered the
hardest climb in the world to some
extent.
It's this thing,
it was a seven year project for him up
up the right side of El Cap.
The thing I climbed on the left side.
Oh Kathy,
he comes something on the right side,
which is much harder,
but he was using a rope and put seven
years of work into it.
And um,
anyway,
years.
Yeah.
And then this Guy Adam,
100 who were watching a video of,
he,
uh,
he did the second ascent and uh,
he put like a month of work into it and
repeated it and you're just like,
whoa,
he's really,
really strong.
Wow.
So when you see a guy do something like
that,
does that make you think about doing it
or do you go,
well that's only something that someone
can do with raw.
With ropes.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean there are whole categories of
climate that can only be done with a
rope because the moves are way too
insecure.
You fall off way too often.
I mean anything that kind of fall off
doing that.
Oh,
like hundreds or maybe even thousands of
times.
So for him to,
for him to do something at the heart,
I mean to,
to climb at the very highest levels of,
of human potential.
I mean,
so think about a gymnast or something
that him right there.
So He's free soloing?
No,
no,
no.
He has a harness on.
He's got a rope right there.
Yeah.
No,
I mean look at what he's holding his one
finger.
No,
I think is the other one might be onto
but,
but it's basically like a tiny,
tiny,
tiny edge.
This is the crux of one of the pitchers
on the dawn wall.
That is so insane.
That guy could probably crush your head
by just grabbing it when certainly the,
he has a certain ferocity,
he has an intensity where you can try
with like 115 percent just like,
ah.
So I'm pretty sure if he grabbed your
head and I tried as hard as it would
just pop like a little melon grip
strength.
He's holding on to such a tiny,
tiny little things.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a very,
very strong wow man.
So a guy like that,
when you see him do these paths,
these paths or paths that you can only
do with a rope?
Yeah.
Does he free solo as well?
I don't think he ever has,
but it's not really his thing.
And the thing that in some ways it's
really hard to do both at a high level
and um,
I,
I think or at least to some extent it's
hard to do both at a high level because.
So for him,
for him to climb something that hard,
he needs that intensity.
He needs a 115 percent effort.
But if you're trying to free Solo,
well you definitely should never be
giving anything even remotely close to
115 percent effort or will die for sure.
Yeah.
Because you're so close to that razor
edge of failure when you're trying that
hard.
But with freestyle and you have to
always keep it sort of within your
comfort zone because you don't want to
die doing it.
So I mean,
I think that I've always sort of kept my
personal,
like you're on your personal barometer
of effort.
I sort of live between four and seven,
let's say,
or like three and a half and seven
maybe.
Where it's like you're never too relaxed
but you're also never going to the
absolute death or sort of like in the
four to six is a sweet spot where you're
like,
I'm climbing,
I'm having a good time.
But I'm not like trying too hard and I'm
not relaxed.
But.
So somebody gotta monitor or Tommy
Caldwell,
like I've,
I've climbed with Tommy a lot over the
years.
He's a great climber and I've really
seen this because he had like,
I've seen him just randomly fall off
many times because he was,
he just slept.
He was like,
Oh,
I'm so relaxed.
It's so easy.
And then it's like,
oh,
I slipped and that's kind of like an
effort of one where you're like,
your body is so relaxed that if,
if anything happens,
then you fall and with,
with a rope on,
that's fine.
In some ways that's the more efficient
way to climb because you know,
you're so relaxed most of the time that
you're saving a lot of energy over all
that every once in a while when you
fall.
It's like,
who cares?
The rope catches you.
It's no problem,
but you have to trust those little
things that you stick in the crowd.
But that's all.
So that's,
I mean,
that's.
Yeah,
that's,
that's kind of like,
what is he doing there?
He's uh,
he's counter pressure me his leg into
this cracked arrest.
He's basically like pushing his knee
into the rock to,
uh,
in order to relax his arms from his
whole body leaning backwards.
Yes.
So he's hanging upside down.
Basically every muscle in his body is
relaxed except for his calf and his calf
is forcing his knee into the rock which
holds them in place.
That is so insane.
That photo is so insane that that's a
really efficient way to rest,
to rest,
to rest.
Your arms will be good.
It's really hard to.
Well,
you know what I mean?
For him it's like for him to be able to
rest like that for one minute is an
amazing way to rest your arms for a
minute and then it sort of saps your
core and it makes us cap really tired.
Obviously.
Now there's a guy like,
does he lift weights or anything to
prepare for these things?
There's just no,
he's doing it.
He's,
he's on his own program,
but it's really climate specific.
He's mostly doing things with his
fingers and yeah,
he's pretty jacked.
Is that even him?
That's crazy.
That's a weird.
Uh,
yeah,
it's the same.
It's the same route.
That's interesting.
I've never seen that photo,
but I mean,
I guess you just get jacked from doing
that too though.
Just constantly pulling yourself up.
Yeah,
for sure.
There's a climbing wall just like local
a kid's place and I told my daughter
give her 100 bucks if she could make it
all the way to the other side.
It's pretty difficult and so she's
become obsessed with trying to get over
that to get 100 bucks.
That's definitely Jack.
I mean look at it.
He's Jack.
Your daughter's going to wind up super
ripped.
It's hard to do my like really?
I tried to do it and I couldn't do it.
I was like,
wow,
this is really hard.
It's difficult to do.
I bet.
I bet if you.
If you try it a bit.
I mean just because you have such a
background in movement and fitness and
everything.
I bet.
I bet it wouldn't be that hard for,
you know,
instruction.
Yeah.
I'm pretty heavy though.
For someone who's short the that'd be an
issue is hanging on $200.
So in theory climbing should be more in
your legs anyway.
She'd be driving with your legs because
no matter what,
your legs are always bigger and stronger
muscles in your arms.
So that's always what drives you upward
and then your arms should only be
holding your weight in and keeping your,
keeping you balanced over your feet
basically.
That's interesting.
That's something that they figured out
fairly recently with grappling over the
last 10,
15 years with Jujitsu and things along
those lines that your legs,
you,
it's really important to use mostly your
legs when you're grappling.
Totally.
I can see that.
I mean that's what's driving you forward
and pushing the whole trolling your
opponent and manipulating your opponent
and doing stuff with your legs.
Do you do anything to cross train?
Like not really,
no other mountain sports,
a little mountain biking or skiing or
things like that.
We do it for fun,
for fun.
And then um,
the only real cross training and it was
just sort of like a pushup and core type
routine,
you know,
like opposition training just to
maintain healthy,
healthy body.
Oh,
because you're constantly pulling.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm always pulling for my sports.
So then I tried to do a little bit of
pushing and core just to make sure that
things stay balanced out.
Now,
is that something you talk to a physical
therapist about or.
No,
that's just.
I mean that's just basic physiology.
I mean if you only pull,
you have to push sometimes throws you
wind up all imbalanced and injured.
Well,
I saw the,
one of the things in the film was when
you were recovering from your ankle
sprain and you know,
you had said that you really hadn't been
injured in years.
Then all of a sudden you have this
girlfriend and she doesn't climb and you
get injured.
Yeah.
That actually is just free.
Free timing.
God luck.
Yeah.
It's just unfortunate because I think
really it just shows that I've been
really fortunate for 20 years that I've
had very few injuries climbing and then,
you know,
at some point you just have a few in
this.
I mean that's just life to some extent,
but when you do have something like that
and you feel sort of the vulnerability
of your tissue and your,
do you think about like,
Hey,
what if this happened halfway up?
Some fucking insane path?
No,
the,
the bigger thing in the film,
uh,
I have a back injury earlier where I get
lowered off the end of the rope and
fall.
I only fell maybe 10 or 12 feet,
you know,
sorta like the height of this,
this room basically.
And,
but I landed sort of like folded over
this rock backward.
It was like totally horrible,
like these jagged good boulders and um,
so I didn't go that far,
but I was like,
oh,
you know,
I got worked and it was really sobering
because it made me realize that if I
fell from 40 feet climbing,
you know,
you could,
it could be.
Yeah,
I mean it'd be a disaster.
You're basically are,
it made me realize just how fragile my
body is because I'm like,
oh,
I only fell a little tiny ways and it
really hurt pretty bad.
I was like,
man,
if you fell much further,
you could,
anything could happen.
Yeah.
People step off stairs wrong and yeah.
It's very strange.
The body's so fragile.
It's really amazing.
Well,
it's funny,
but it's so fragile.
But then also so robust in some ways.
I mean,
it's amazing what the human body can
adapt to or withstand,
but then yeah,
and then some things just cannot.
Yeah.
That's why I was asking you about your
age,
like as you get older,
are you seeing a difference in the way
you recover?
Are you seeing differences in the way
you know,
like what your body,
what you feel like your potential is?
I,
yeah.
It's hard to say.
I think.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean those are the tough questions.
I mean,
you know,
I'm sure.
Sure you think about this stuff too.
Was a fighter a fighter at your age?
Thirty three?
He said.
Yeah.
That's when you start tailing off like
winding down 34,
35 on a fighter,
hits like 36.
Like yikes.
Is that,
is that like old for fighter?
That's pretty old.
It's very rare.
There's only a few guys who've been able
to compete at a world class level past
that.
And MMA.
Randy coture stands out and boxing.
Bernard Hopkins stands out.
How old is the Floyd Mayweather?
He's 40.
Wow.
Is he still considered like fighting an
elite level?
Well,
you know,
when he fought conor mcgregor,
conor mcgregor was nowhere near his
level because conor mcgregor wasn't
really a box.
He's on boxer and so floyd just kind of
worked him.
But uh,
he hasn't really fought at a world class
level for a couple of years because,
you know,
he beat Canelo Alvarez several years ago
and made Canelo drop a ton of weight
when he beat Manny Pacquiao.
Manny Pacquiao was quite a bit past his
prime and had a shoulder injury.
So you probably dealing with like three
years or so since he's fought like real
world class competition.
Huh?
When you say you made them drop lunch,
wait,
does that mean like to.
How does that work?
Clever.
You know,
he,
he wanted him to fight at a lower weight
class,
you know,
because floyd really,
floyd started off his career,
I want to say at 1:30.
Then he fought at 1:45.
Yeah.
And you know,
his real isn't any big.
How big is it?
At least a very small five,
six,
five,
seven,
maybe five,
seven.
Tiny little hands on.
Very small hands.
But certainly they hit very hard.
Well,
he's not a very fast,
he's just a genius boxer.
Probably one of the best defense,
probably if not the best,
definitely top two or three boxers of
all time.
It's only been really hit hard to the
point where it's been wobbled like maybe
like four,
four times his entire career.
It seems like that's the kind of box
that you want to be.
Exactly.
You know what it'd be like the rocky
Balboa styled,
so that just gets beaten to death and
then you want to be as boring really
frigging watching NFL games with good
defense and you're like,
oh man.
It's like not the team you want to
watch,
but it's probably the better team.
Yeah,
well especially with boxing because the
consequences are so grave.
If you hit a lot,
there was a horrible video that I put up
on youtube or on twitter rather than a
retweeted.
Someone sent me and it's boxers when
they're young talking versus after
injuries and you're watching,
you're like,
whoa.
It's stunning.
It's just like nfl stuff too.
I mean,
yeah,
it's funny.
I mean people talk about that with
climbing.
It's like,
oh,
that's such a dangerous sport,
but the thing about rock climbing is
that it's basically a completely safe
sport right up until some kind of
accident may happen and then then you
potentially die.
But so the thing is you can basically
climb at a high level for 50 years and
never have any issues or you could maybe
die doing it,
but it's kind of a fundamentally safe
sport for the most part as opposed to
what we're talking about,
like fighting or a football or things
like that were like,
or even mountain biking where you're for
sure going to get injured like no matter
what,
just by,
just by playing the game,
you know,
like football and fighting,
they creep up on you,
like the injuries start to pile.
But basically just even in practice you
are getting injured constantly,
you know?
And so it's,
I mean that's Kinda messed up.
It's just the price of entry is going to
be freaking head injuries.
Yeah.
I went to a football game.
You have the day high school football
game.
And um,
when I was there,
I,
I had a really hard time watching it
because everybody's cheering and um,
and I was talking to my friend,
I'm like,
you're looking at brain damage.
Yeah,
no one's messed up here.
These kids are getting brain damage and
this is like a really nice private
school where they pay a lot of money to
get the kids into this program.
And then the kids are playing football.
I'm like,
these are all getting brain damage.
He goes,
really?
I go,
oh,
100 percent.
I go,
do you see that collision?
That's brain damage.
That's definitely brain damage.
It might not be a lot.
They might be okay,
but how many of those do they do in a
day?
How many do they do?
How many a month?
How many are there?
What are ways to human potential right
there?
I'm just like,
well,
it really is.
I mean,
the problem is it's such a grand part of
our history and our culture,
which doesn't really need to be.
I mean,
you know,
football hasn't existed that alarm.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
I mean,
I'm not,
I forgot.
Shit,
I watched a Rodeo from like very,
very close basically like from the
commentators box,
like above the pens for the fourth of
July Rodeo in Wyoming like two summers
ago.
And that was something I was like,
this is messed up.
I mean,
and I'm not like huge animal rights guy
but I'm vegetarian obviously and I sort
of care.
And I was like,
Oh,
you know,
you're kind of abusing these animals for
sport and that's like,
that doesn't sit that well with me.
But what was even worse,
I was like,
all these young men are getting worked
just like for the entertainment is
totally like Roman gladiator type stuff.
And I was just like.
And it's weird because it's so cultural,
you know,
because,
and,
and you know,
I mean I can,
I can empathize because obviously I'm
doing something that's also sort of
bloodsport he to some extent and,
and sort of for the same reason,
you know,
you're a teenage do look into do
something interesting and engaging
that's,
that will hopefully get you laid,
you know,
like you just want to.
I mean,
if you're from small town Wyoming and
you're like,
oh,
I'm good at riding bowls,
like that's for sure going to be your
path.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's just too bad that that's your
path.
It's a path.
I mean we watched this guy get fricking
thrown off this bowl and um,
and I think he was fine,
you know,
he landed on the ground,
but then the bowl for Canada was
charging him and the guy like,
I've never seen human terror,
like he basically just turned and ran as
fast as he could,
but he ran straight into this post,
like headfirst into this frickin steel
posts,
like the edge of the.
Because he just didn't,
you know,
it was like the bolts coming at him.
He like turns it around and you
basically like knocks himself out
against this post.
And thankfully the clowns distracted the
bowl.
And then the paramedics,
he believed there was a brigade
ambulance basically parked on the other
side of the fence from what you read do.
And so they basically like lift him over
and put them straight on the stretcher
and take them away.
You know what I was like dude,
and you know the crowds all like,
ah,
and you're just like that guys like
messed up like that,
you know,
everything about it made me like,
feel kind of gross,
you know?
Yeah.
It's not like I would never want to pay
to watch somebody hurt themselves or
just like,
I dunno.
Well it's weird that that's culturally
acceptable,
but like bullfighting is not.
Yeah.
When they're totally.
Bull riding.
It's like they're fricking tasing the
bowls that are like,
aren't they tying off their balls and
they're doing all kinds of things and
some bad things too though.
People argue that the polls have great
lives,
you know,
they feed them well and they get a lot
of exercise and they're very happy bowls
and you're like,
dude,
I'm pretty sure they'd rather be roaming
the open plains,
like inseminating cows,
you know?
Yeah.
That's weird.
Justification.
Yeah.
We had a guy on fear factor
for once that was a professional rodeo
guy and his shoulder was like a
topographic map and he had so many scars
in his shoulder and he told me,
you show that would just pop out just
like he could just pop it out left and
right from just being destroyed like
Ford by bolts falling and getting it
ripped apart or riding bowls.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I just,
I just don't get that just wasn't
working anymore.
I mean he had a bunch of surgeries and
they tried to screw it back together and
tighten things down,
but it was just destroyed.
So I'm sure.
I'm sure a bull rider would look at free
soloing.
It'd be like,
what a crazy dude.
You know,
everybody looks at another sport and
they're like,
that's great.
And honestly I look at fighting and I'm
like,
that seems totally outrageous.
I'm like,
why would you want some other dude beat
you to death in a cage?
I'm like,
that's great.
He's outrageous.
It is outrageous.
But if you can get good enough where you
can avoid getting damage.
Yeah.
And then the tool to land the damage,
it's Kinda the same,
but even landing the damage to a certain
extent,
you're like,
oh,
you're hurting somebody else for the
pleasure of the crowd.
You're like,
that's Kinda messed up.
You know,
it's a weird feeling.
Knocking someone is one of the
weirdest feelings because a part of you
is happy that it's not you,
but part of you is like looking down
with that guy that's just got flatlined
and you're like,
Whoa,
that could have been made.
How much to fighters?
Like,
hold back,
you know,
because I feel like you kind of have to
like go to the death.
But then if you actually like punch
somebody so hard,
they died or something.
I mean obviously you'd feel horrible or
it will.
You don't look back at all.
But that's insane.
But.
So it's like you don't hold back at all,
but then if you actually killed somebody
when you feel horrible.
It's very rare that someone dies in
mixed martial arts,
believe it or not.
Well yeah.
No,
I mean I know that,
but it's possible.
Definitely possible.
And it has happened and it's sort of
like it has happened very,
very rarely in mixed martial arts.
Never in the UFC.
But in boxing it happens more often.
And one of the reasons why it happens
more often in boxing because you're only
punching in,
then you're taking people down.
Yeah.
People are tapping out cause they're
paying them.
Well.
It's also there's more options to defend
yourself.
You're not just getting battered against
the ropes.
They're also nowadays much better at
stopping a fight when a fighter's
clearly compromised when they're.
They're really fucked up.
In the old days they used to let guys
just get battered.
They're just a box that doesn't sit well
with me.
I'm just like,
ah,
but that's what I'm not a fighter.
Well that's the thing about climbing is
there's this real elemental appeal to
just you and the mountain and it's
nature and it's beautiful and it's very
peaceful and calm.
It's like so different than having
thousands of people screaming at you as
you punch someone in the face over and
over.
Just like,
dude,
that's just not my scene.
Well,
did you see the economy?
Mcgregor could be abnormal gromit off
fight where there's the big fight
outside the cage.
Always.
That's the thing where the guy vaults
out of the cage and like starts bawling.
I was like,
yeah,
it's like wwe or whatever it was.
When did they start breaking tables over
people crazier than that because it was
real.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was like,
this is totally outrageous,
but what's funny is it became chaos
because a fight erupted outside of the
parameters of the fight.
It was just more fighting,
fighting.
You have like,
this is what we paid for,
this isn't okay.
Right.
Everybody's like fighting in the cage is
fine.
This is lovely,
but because out of the cage,
oh my God,
he's out in the wild.
That's like out in the world fighting.
Isn't that kind of messed up?
Yeah.
It's definitely like he's a professional
fighter.
He's fighting.
That's what he does.
It's weird though,
the whole list and then this is coming
from someone who's been involved in this
my whole life.
It's weird.
It's.
I,
I absolutely see all the arguments
against it and yet you still want to go
to trader when people in the face.
I don't punch anybody in the face
anymore.
I still choke people.
But uh,
I think that seems totally fun.
The thing about the Jujitsu aspect of it
is you,
you really can tap out and stop and you
don't really get hurt.
You get hurt training.
Jujitsu's accidental for the most part.
Especially when you train,
you're actually better off training with
a black belt than you are with a white
belt doorway because.
Yeah,
no,
I get that blacks,
they have more control on,
so they'll be fine with you.
They'll just,
they'll just tap you and yeah,
it was a white ball accident and kicks
you in the face and you're like,
ah,
spark really strong.
Especially if you get a white belt is a
crossfitter,
is fucking jacked.
Really strong guide.
Just wants to.
They probably were just grappling and
then as a harm came out and I don't know
what to do with it,
so I threw it away.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Really unskilled guy who's extremely
strong,
who's learning technique,
and it's also like a spazz is very
dangerous to roll.
Uh,
so yeah,
you don't want to teach me to Jujitsu.
It's not me telling you if you did it
with me we'd be fine.
But if you did it with someone who's a
real beginner,
who's,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm a strong beginner,
strong grip and no idea what I'm doing.
Just like,
yeah,
book.
The real problem would be if we were
both beginners yoga,
that would be the real problem.
Like a strong spazz is not really not
going to work against the black belt.
That's a go.
That's the learning curve for climate
and who you don't want to.
Beginners going out and trying to climb
a mountain together.
I would worry about that.
Like if you're climbing,
do you ever climb?
Like is there a chain like one person in
front of you?
Like when you.
Yeah,
when you climb up the rope,
it's basically two people.
One goes out first and then brings up
the second because you're limited by the
length of the rope.
So basically one person,
because at the end of the rope brings up
the next person,
that person that climbs through brings
it up the second,
so you dependent upon the holes that
they put in when they put those bolts
into the cracks and bolts,
bolts and things are put in by the first
essential list.
So the very first person to have ever
climbed the route,
but then everybody thereafter is able to
just clip there.
Their equipment into the bolts are a use
preestablished anchors,
things like that.
Oh.
So all the,
all the roots are already established
and you can read a book that shows all
the different routes.
So like El captain has something like
112 different roots of it and wow.
And of those hundred and 12,
only 15 or so of them can be free
climbed,
which is different than free soloing.
Free climbing,
meaning just using your hands and your
feet and you're still using a rope.
You're still clipping into protection as
you go,
but you're only using your hands and
your feet to get you up as opposed to
like putting gear in.
And then pulling on the gear which would
be considered cheating.
So of the 100 routes on Ocap,
something like 90 of them you have to
pull on the hardware,
you have to like clip little ladders
into it and step on,
you know,
you have to hammer pecans in and then
clip into them and stand on and then
hammer another town and step on.
That is no flip for.
Yeah,
there's just nothing to hold onto.
It's too hard.
So then,
so then there,
yeah,
something like 10 or 15 free climbing
routes where you can climate.
And so with my big goal of trying to
free Solo El cap to climbing without a
rope,
I was limited to just those 10 or 15
routes that are possible to climb.
Just with your hands and feet.
And how did you establish the one that
you wanted to proceed on?
Yeah,
so basically I just wanted them doing
the easiest one because I'm basically,
it's really hard to free climb El cap by
any means.
And so the easiest one wound up being
the most secure.
The best one for me.
How many people have done it?
Will Free Solo or free climb free solo
freestyle.
I'm,
I mean,
nobody only web the only one.
Yeah,
I mean that's why there's
the film and everything.
It's,
it's a.
and nobody's ever even thought about it,
you know,
nobody's considered.
It's not like something that people are
trying to do.
Now that you've done it.
Other,
other people that are considering it.
I really don't.
I mean,
I think it's almost more the opposite
now that I've done it.
People are like,
Whoa,
I don't need to do that every.
I mean,
there's nobody even playing this game
right now.
Really.
There aren't that many high end free
soloist right now.
How many other um,
to one or something really.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know if there are any others
really right now there's this guy brad
go right.
And then the American guy who's been
freestyling at a pretty high level,
but definitely he's a really good friend
of mine,
so I'm not slandering him.
But,
um,
but definitely at a very different level
than,
uh,
like he would never even dream of
selling all cab.
So he's sort of starting out was not
that he's starting out,
I mean he's a very good climber,
he's been climbing with long time and
he's done all kinds of very difficult
things.
But in terms of free soloing,
I think he just doesn't need to push it
as that hard.
So he's almost like he dabbles in free
soloing.
Yeah.
Well I mean I dabble on free soloing as
well.
I mean most of them I'm climbing with my
friends doing other things,
you know,
I mean I think most almost all climbers
only dabbling free.
So free soloing is sort of like one
discipline of climbing.
Like when we were talking earlier about
the Olympics,
having multiple disciplines,
um,
you know there are many types of
climbing and most climbers do all of
them to some extent and free soloing
always represents sort of this small
specialty like extra style.
So you do free climbing and then you
also do the kind of climbing where you
have to put in those posts and stand on
them.
Our aid climbing,
artificial climate.
So I free climb,
I aid climb.
Sometimes I don't like to because it's
too much work,
it's too much like construction,
you know,
you're like nailing things and standing
on.
It's like engineering,
but I do that because sometimes that's
what it requires to get up big mountains
and we do that.
And you nail things and stand on them.
Do you take them out as well?
Yeah,
the second person takes them out so the
one person uses them to get up and then
once the rope is security above,
then the second person joins them and
remove them all.
And then you have all your gear back and
then you're able to do it again for the
next section.
How much weight is that stuff?
Well,
it depends where it can be a lot.
And certainly back in the day when
people were doing the first ascents of
El Cap,
I mean it's something like 40 pounds or
50 pounds of iron hanging off him.
Jesus.
Nowadays it's a lot lighter and you can
use better gear.
But um,
but yeah,
I mean it's a lot,
but that's kind of the appeal of free
climbing or even free soloing means that
you have nothing on you.
Now,
how secure is that stuff that you're
hammering in there?
It depends.
I mean there's certainly stories of
people falling and ripping all this
stuff back up,
but,
but sometimes that's okay because if
you're,
if you're thousands of feet off the
ground,
you can take that hundred foot fall and
not touch anything and it's fun.
Oh yeah.
But still not really earlier this
summer,
a county on the thing.
Yeah,
I mean it's all,
it's all well founded.
I mean,
you just got to trust it.
Now,
earlier this summer I was talking about
Tommy Caldwell,
one of the best climbers in the country.
So the two of us did the speed record on
ocap cap earlier this year.
And so that's the two of us are tied
together.
We're using a rope,
we're using equipment,
but we're anything goes,
you're cheating as much as you can,
as it trying to get from the bottom of
the cap to the top as fast as possible.
This is on a different route than the
one that I presented in the film.
And so,
um,
we were trying to go sub two hours and
we ultimately did it and 1:58
and it was,
it was pretty awesome and we were really
psyched.
But along the way Tommy took 100 foot
fall at one point where he just,
I was talking about him with the whole
one to 10 effort.
He was climbing something that's really,
really easy and he was probably giving
an effort of like two and he just
slipped,
you know,
and I was like,
oh,
but anyway,
he freakin whipped.
You felt like a hundred feet just
straight down the wall.
Didn't touch anything because I'll.
Cap is like a very clean vertical sheet
rock.
How long does it take to fall?
One hundred feet.
That's like several.
Yeah,
several seconds.
No,
no,
like four or five or something.
But you accelerated very quickly to
three long enough to be like,
oh my God,
I'm going to die.
No,
no,
no.
Long enough.
So the reason he fell so far is because
we were doing this sort of complicated
maneuvers.
Uh,
normally I would have a blade advice on.
I basically,
it would be attached to the rope earlier
to like catch him,
but I'd taken my blade of ice off and I
was just tied into the end.
So basically he fell on all the slack,
whipped through until it hit me at the
end of the rope.
But so when he yelled,
I basically had time to be like,
oh my God,
he's falling,
like brace for impact.
Like knowing that in a second the rope
is going to come tight against the end
that I'm tied into basically jerk me.
But then thankfully there's enough drag
and the system that it didn't jerk me
off the stance that I was on or else I
would have gotten pulled like 15 feet
across the wall and it was all messed
up.
So when he's falling and you're,
you're realizing that you're going to
get yanked by his fault or you like
digging into the,
you know,
basically I was like,
oh my God,
you know,
it was like brace yourself.
Like I was in this position.
I was actually facing out away from the
wall,
like facing out towards the meadow
because I was in an open corner.
Like if you look at the corner of the
room,
imagine one leg on each side facing
outward,
like pushed into this position because
it's like I was about to have to untie
my knot and retire and do some things.
And so I was basically like already to
do some things and all of a sudden I
hear that he's falling and I was like,
oh my God.
And then like I was able to just sorta
like stick in there Jesus.
But my point is just that taking big
fall.
I mean if you trust your equipment and
everything,
it can be okay to take big falls like
that.
You obviously try to avoid them because
you know,
had he hit a ledge or something,
then potentially he could have died,
but because it was,
it was clean there it was.
Okay.
So if he was in a situation where there
was a slight angle and he fell that far,
that's where it's really dangerous.
I mean worst case scenario would be if
he fell 100 feet and 75 feet down there
was alleged sticking out how half the
width of this table because then you
would just clip it,
you'd break both your legs,
everything would explode and then you'd
still know what do you do if you fall
and you break something and you're
halfway up.
We'll do so.
Okay.
Same route.
The nose of El Cap,
which we were trying to do the speed
record on this friend of mine who I
actually previously held the speed
record with this older guy,
Hans flooring,
um,
who actually wrote the book how to speed
climb that.
I learned how to speed come from many
years ago.
So he freaking exactly what I'm
describing.
Sort of worst case scenario.
He took this 20,
probably a 22 foot fall,
but he was unlucky enough,
which is totally fine.
He had a rope.
You had gear.
Everything worked exactly the way it's
supposed to.
He just fell always,
which,
which is normal,
but the bummer was that there was a
little ledge,
probably twice the size of that box
right there,
like that little wooden box,
just kind of this little thing sticking
out from the wall about this far that
basically he fell 20 feet hit that,
broke both of his ankles and then and
then went off in another two feet and so
the rope caught him and you know,
the fall was exactly as expected.
All his gear held.
Everything's totally normal except that
he happened to hit that thing right at
the apex of the full force of his fall.
You know,
I hid that legend two feet below.
It wouldn't matter at all.
He would just hidden,
jumped off into space,
but because you'd already fallen 20
feet,
broke both his ankles and then he was
kind of horrible.
I was actually up higher on the wall
that day.
I'd come in from above to repel in and
work on something and I heard him
yelling,
but I thought he was just hooting and
hollering like,
hey,
you know,
how's it going type deal.
And then I like it climbed out to the
summit and then when I'd hiked halfway
back down I got a voicemail from him
saying that,
um,
you know,
being like,
oh,
hey,
it's Honda.
I think I've just broken my,
my tip fib.
Um,
you know,
basically like,
oh,
can you,
can you help her with her?
He'd already called search and rescue
and so rescue is already mobilized,
but search and rescue in Yosemite,
it's really lead.
They're really fast but it's still sort
of by the books,
you know,
it still takes kind of a lot of time.
And so I was like,
Oh man,
like maybe I should run back up and
repel down and like help my buddy repel
down the wall again or something.
Try to like get them out of here faster
just because when search and rescue
mobilize,
it's like a long time.
And I was like,
if he's in a lot of pain that,
that sucks,
you know,
um,
there as it,
I really hesitated.
I wound up calling search and rescue and
talking to through them to see if there
was anything I could do to help.
But ultimately I want them just going
down because there wasn't really
anything for me to do.
So he's essentially just suspending for
awhile waiting for them to get them.
Yeah.
So he basically just sat on the ledge
with two broken legs for,
you know,
six hours or 12 hours or something.
And then eventually they managed to haul
him up to the summit and then I think
they helicoptered him off the next
morning because it was already dark by
then.
Yeah,
I know it was kind of horrible.
But he sort of recovered by now it's
been,
it's been five months or something.
So he's back at it,
always climbing.
He's the manager of a climate.
He's,
you know.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it's two broken bones.
I mean worse,
it seems like.
No,
super grim.
It was like.
But that's an example of sort of worst
case,
you know,
just bad luck.
Well that's actually not worst case
right now that.
Yeah,
that's not worst case.
That's just bad luck.
Yeah.
That's like when you're sitting there,
if you're sitting there hanging off a
ledge like that with two broken ankles
for six hours.
I mean that must be grim,
but I don't get to you the super groom
swelling and yeah.
So I think he and his partner actually
repelled down 100 feet to a slightly
bigger ledge so that he could lay on it
and elevate his legs.
And then I think there were some other
climbers around that game,
a jacket,
you know,
so he gets sort of bundle up and like
lay there and sort of manage.
But yeah,
I mean it seems extremely character
building the life you choose.
Yeah.
No,
it's really,
I'm that,
that actually kind of makes me feel
really bad.
You could just.
Because the like that kind of thing is
really close to home because he's a
friend and it's just so bad.
Yeah.
Not can only imagine.
When,
when you think about your life and you
think about this stuff that you do,
do you do,
is there a point where you feel like you
won't do it anymore or a point where you
feel like you want free solo anymore?
Or do you look at like your friend who
you were talking about who's older,
who's still free soloing and doing
difficult paths?
Do you think this is just your life
forever?
Um,
no.
I don't know.
I honestly,
I'm not sure.
I don't think it's my path forever
necessarily just because there just
aren't always bigger and harder things
to do.
You know what I mean?
El Cap represented sort of the end of
this very long road for me.
I mean I,
I sold many,
many things that we're all sort of
leading towards El Cap and then I
finally did that and that.
And at least right now I can't really
imagine anything more inspiring to me.
Uh,
in terms of reselling,
I mean there are plenty of other climate
challenges that I'm interested in.
Like I was just saying,
doing the speed record is something that
I did this summer,
but
is this like winning a big hand in Vegas
where you're just like,
okay,
we got all the money
the fuck out of here?
No,
because that's that.
That is too much luck.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's more like realizing a life dream
and you're sort of like,
okay,
yeah,
boundary I've seen.
But I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's a similar idea where you're like,
okay,
I will.
No,
it's not even.
I mean it's.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's a bad analogy just in terms of
like,
no,
no more big crazy risks.
Yeah.
But that's the thing is that it's not
even,
I was never seen as a big crazy risk,
you know,
I wasn't what was or wasn't rolling the
dice.
I was sort of training for this thing
and then I did it and I'm just not sure
if there's a bigger thing that's worth
more effort,
you know?
So I don't know.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
as you've seen the film,
like our relationship with my girlfriend
and she's great and we have this nice
life together and there's so much else
in climbing and um,
you know,
I mean maybe I'll never,
never seek out big free soloing
challenges again.
I mean,
we'll see
now you're still relatively young in
terms of life itself.
Do you,
do you think maybe there could be
something that you would enjoy as much
as you enjoy climbing?
Well,
I mean,
so no matter what I'll climb my whole
life.
I mean,
I forgetting,
I love climbing.
I mean even on the phone here,
I'm climbing in the gym everyday and
just for the movement of it just to
enjoy climbing.
But,
um,
I don't know,
I'm,
I,
I have a foundation that I've worked
with for the last five or six years
supporting solar around the world.
And so,
um,
I could see putting more and more effort
into that.
I mean,
that's something that satisfying in a
way that climbing sort of isn't because
it actually has a real tangible impact
on the world.
You know,
mean climbing is really fulfilling
personally,
but when it's all said and done,
it's like it's just me going rock
climbing,
it doesn't really matter,
but um,
but at least working with the
foundation,
it's like actually doing something real.
What is your foundation?
Just the foundation,
but it's a,
we've been supporting solar all this.
I mean if you want the version is
basically uh,
you know,
I was looking for some way to do
something positive in the world.
So I was looking to support
environmental projects and then I was
like,
there's no real point in supporting
environmental projects that don't also
support in like increased standard of
living that like help people in need.
And that sort of led me to solar
projects basically solar energy access.
And so that's what we in sport in the
last five,
six years.
And so what do you do with this project
was so domestically it was,
it mostly,
it's just been my way of donating my
money to two other projects that support
solar.
So I'm domestically in the US,
I've been supporting this group,
grid alternatives for example,
I'm in.
So,
I mean,
I've done a few ins,
installations with them in,
in Sacramento,
in my hometown were basically low income
family,
just gets a free home solar system on
their house and so it saves them the
energy bills,
but then also in terms of carbon
emissions is just,
it's good for the planet,
you know,
slowly greening the grid.
But um,
and then the bigger potentially the
bigger impacts have been projects we've
been supporting in Africa,
I'm just give access to solar lantern,
solar lights,
being able to charge cell phones
basically like small scale systems that
was just a panel,
a battery and a few led lights and an
iphone charger.
But um,
but those kinds of things can
fundamentally change somebody's life
because,
you know,
east Africa people can spend up to a
quarter of their income on kerosene
light just to light their home,
which is totally outrageous.
I mean imagine spending that percentage
of your income just to have light after
dark,
you know,
and like an equatorial regions of the
earth.
It's dark for 12 hours a day.
I mean,
imagine if when the sun goes down,
your productive hours are done,
you're just like,
I'm just going to sit in the dark for 12
hours.
It's crazy,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean there,
there are a billion people on earth
living without access to power and I
mean it's hard not for.
I mean I kind of see that as a waste of
human potential to some extent.
Like it's just an unfortunate thing to
think there are so many people living
without access to power.
I mean,
it's crazy.
It is crazy.
It's really crazy in California that
there's not more solar.
When you think about how often it's
sunny here,
he.
Yeah,
no,
I mean it's,
it's totally that.
I mean at least it's,
it's growing very quickly in California
at least.
But I mean really solar should be
powering the whole or I mean enough
sunlight hits the earth every.
I don't know the terms.
It's every like 10 or 15 minutes
basically to power the earth for like
the year.
If you're able to harness all that
energy,
just kind of like.
It's just such a cleaner,
simpler way of of powering the earth,
you know?
Yeah.
It really is.
And I mean one can only hope that that's
going to.
It's going to keep continue.
It's gonna continue to evolve and the
thing,
the thing that drives me absolutely
crazy is that it.
It's totally obvious that in 100 years
the earth will be run through solar and
things like that because there's just so
much energy spilling onto the earth and
it's free.
And so the technology is only improving.
Everybody's adopting it like in 100
years,
no question.
Everything will be run from the sun.
The thing that drives me insane is that
there's so much resistance to it from
utilities,
from,
from consumer ignorance,
from whatever else,
but people just don't totally get it and
sort of opposed to it.
And so,
you know,
half the world will be dragged kicking
and screaming into the future and you're
sort of like,
if you just embrace it and get there in
15 years instead of 100 years,
all,
all the arguments about climate change,
all the arguments about,
you know,
environmental degradation,
all those kinds of things will be
mitigated to a large extent.
And you sort of like,
is there a downside to that?
You know,
like even if you don't believe in
climate change,
even if you know,
you denial the science behind it,
you think it's all bs.
It's like,
is there really a downside to just
adopting the future sooner?
For me it's like,
yeah,
it's like one of those things where
you're sort of like,
if it's going to happen eventually,
let's just do it now and save all the
fricken hassle again.
There.
I think it's the momentum of the current
system.
It's very difficult for people to just
abandoned established ways of doing
things,
especially down.
We're so hooked on fossil fuels.
I know,
but like it's just such a bummer that
the status quo is such a thing.
You know,
people are like,
oh,
that's the way we do it.
Let's just keep doing that.
And it's just weird because there's so
many things in life,
the change so frequently,
you know,
like I mean the world is constantly
changing and you're like,
let's just embrace the changes that
matter the most and just do them faster.
Well,
you're talking about was a guy who
he lives in a van and climbs rocks
business people that have thousands and
thousands of employees and millions if
not billions of money of dollars
invested in these things.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
that's the problem with parents system.
I know it's just too bad.
Yeah,
but it's.
It is,
but it's inevitable.
I agree with you.
It's inevitable that we will embrace it
and change.
I think
that's almost more frustrating though,
is because it's inevitable and yet it's
going to be dragged out so long.
You're sort of like,
why can't people just embrace the
inevitability of it and just
move forward?
Well,
I think they slowly are,
but things like that take time.
I think one,
one big thing is going to be if they can
ever figure out a way to solar power
cars as you're driving them,
so you never really have to concern
yourself.
I'll ever be a thing.
Well,
fisker figured out how to do it with
your stereo.
They figured out how to do it with your
radio system and different kind of car.
It is,
it's like a lot less energy,
but it's just the roof panel.
The roof panel,
isn't that,
didn't we?
Um,
they,
they are a weird company though.
That's the company that,
um,
many years ago there was a big storm
that hit the east coast and they had a
bunch of cars parked at a dock and they
all exploded when the water hit them and
they realize,
wait,
wait.
You can't get your things drenched in
water.
Like when the water hit a certain level,
like they had a severe flaw and so they
burst into flames and exploded.
And there's this whole like doc filled
with these fisker Karma Karmas that blew
up.
And they called them Karmas,
which has even more hilarious.
You watch it exploding.
That's pretty bad.
That's all bad all the way around.
Yeah.
I think they've since fixed that,
but yeah,
it was a big flaw.
So that's.
I was just actually reading,
I was reading this business management
book,
but um,
if you're talking about the Ford Pinto
with a freaking gas tanks too close to
the back bumper is based in your gas
tank,
protected by nature
and you know,
speaking of exploding cards,
but that actually I think killed lots of
people because they were actually put
into production and then there are tons
of accidents and the car's explode and
you're just like,
man,
that's been a bad decisions that an auto
manufacturing.
Yeah,
the Pinto was a disaster.
It wasn't good.
But yeah,
I think what the,
what they're capable of doing right now,
I think you're right.
I don't think you can power a car with
solar panels completely.
I mean,
you certainly can from your house.
That was their initial claim when they
announced it,
that it would power the whole car and
everyone was like,
that's bullshit.
You know,
that's definitely a bullshit.
I mean,
just.
Yeah.
I have to go two years ago they said
they could power the whole car with the
roof.
August of 2016.
Huh?
I'm trying to find a updates,
but that seems.
That seems totally outrageous because
also,
I mean the future of cars is born like a
smaller car with no,
like a glass roof,
like Tesla style where it's sort of a
initial ad right here.
So a roof create enough energy to power
the car.
No other vehicles sold in the US has
ever offered this capability.
What I mean,
so that might be true if it just sat
parked in the sun for 12 hours and then
he drove home run.
I mean the driveway.
You worked at night charges all day and
you and your commutes really short.
Yeah.
But the numbers don't really don't work
well.
You would know better than anybody if
you're involved in solar.
I don't know,
but I mean there's solar panels of
today.
I mean,
I have a buddy of mine that does a lot
of backpacking and he carries around
this,
uh,
it's like a foldable solar charger for
his phone and he folds it up and lays it
out and then puts a charger there and
then he uses that charger to charge his
phone,
but he doesn't like he'll go 20 plus
days with justice thing you want me to.
So I mentioned our expedition to
Antarctica last winter,
so that's 24 hours of sunlight because
you're in Antarctica and in their summer
and our entire expedition was run from
solar and so we'd actually taken a
generator and the other guys on the trip
for oil,
for the generator basically.
And so it wasn't gonna work.
And so we're like,
oh,
I guess we'll have to try to use the
solar,
which has sort of been our backup
system.
And uh,
it actually,
we ran the whole trip on solar and
everything worked in,
so they were filming.
So there are a bunch of cameras,
a bunch of batteries,
laptops,
backing up drives.
And then,
uh,
they were flying a drone quite a bit for
aerial footage.
Is all kind of beautiful,
so I mean they basically ran this whole
operation off solar.
One of the,
one of the camera guys has got Pablo,
he's a good friend.
Mine.
I'm basically just had to wake up every
two hours to move the panels around the
tent as the sun tracks around this guy,
you know,
so that it's always in full sun.
But um,
and he had to sleep with the batteries
and things to make sure things stay warm
enough.
But otherwise,
I mean,
but that's,
I mean because it's really cold.
Yeah.
It's funny because you put your laptops
and stuff into coolers,
like in the ice chest to keep them
insulated enough to stay warm as opposed
to cold water because the outside
temperature is so cold.
But it was cool though because you know,
that way we didn't have to run this like
loud,
stinky,
annoying generator in like you just have
your panels working fulltime.
Yeah.
That's one of the weird things about
like Tesla's when you drive it in and
they're like,
yeah,
no,
it's awesome.
Yeah.
So much more peaceful.
I mean,
but that's the future.
It's like if you imagine a city that's
all silent electric cars,
no emissions.
I mean imagine how much more pleasant
the pedestrian experiences when they,
when it's not like diesel exhaust right
next to you on the city streets.
Yeah.
You don't hear the car that runs you
over or you know,
but you still do though because uh,
something like 30 percent of the noises,
the tires.
It's like you still hear cars.
Yeah.
But,
but it's just so much more mellow.
You don't hear like an engine like
ripping right by you.
Yeah.
I think it's inevitable that we figured
out a way that you can just power
everything from solar and including cars
as you're driving them.
I mean,
don't make sense as the technology
improves mean.
Yeah,
we'll see.
We'll see.
I mean there's development in a solar
film sort of in windows like so imagine
an office building where the windows are
all producing power.
So I mean if you think about that with a
car,
if it's just like a glass dome over you,
but it's all sort of producing power.
No,
that'd be.
I mean it's pretty amazing.
I have a watch that was on solar power.
That's not a lot of power,
but still,
I mean,
you don't really need any batteries for
Casio.
Yeah,
I do.
When I was a kid,
I'd want to.
Yeah,
that's pretty.
That's pretty straightforward though.
It's a small amount of power that it's
drawing.
When you got involved in this,
um,
how much preparation did you do?
I mean,
what,
what was,
what was the motivation for the
foundation?
Yeah.
Um,
I mean honestly,
like I said,
I was just looking to do something
positive for the world and so exploring
options you will and so I was going to
start donating significant percentage of
my income to,
to environmental nonprofits and then I
decided that I should do it in sort of a
public facing way in,
in the form of the foundation just
because I felt like I'm never going to
have nearly as much money as,
as real philanthropic organization,
you know,
like the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation.
Like I'll never have it.
I'll never have real dollars like that,
but I do sort of have this platform like
some sort of public persona,
whatever.
And so I was like,
well,
at least if I donate things that I can
sort of leverage that in the right way
to contribute,
I don't know,
basically try and maximize the good that
I'm doing.
And so,
um,
yeah,
so then I just started researching
organizations that I felt like we're
doing great work and that led me to
solar basically does most of your income
come from sponsors and from public
appearances,
like how it was mostly sponsors and then
it sort of has shifted into sponsors and
sort of one off things.
So like,
um,
I published a book a few years ago and
so there's an advanced from that and
like the film has made a little money,
um,
the random little things in the now it's
also sort of split with corporate
speaking type commercial opportunities
as well.
So sponsorship is still probably the
biggest thing for me.
So like the northface been my biggest
sponsor,
um,
and most important sponsor for me.
But then now it's sort of split between
a bunch of different sources,
just sort of public speaking things have
these corporate appearances.
You just go and get,
just talk to them about free solo
climbing and yeah,
talk to them about climate.
Talking about preparation or I mean
depends on what somebody needs.
Really.
It depends what the organizations I've
spoken to a bunch of a venture capital
firms about risk taking and risk
management or how that's interesting,
you know,
so they just look at you as like sort of
an inspiration to mix things up for the
company.
Yeah,
I mean I'd like to think that it's a
slightly more interesting topic than the
average business speaker,
you know,
I mean it's certainly more beautiful
images,
you know,
like if I,
if I give a nice slideshow and chat for
a bit,
it's um,
you know,
I mean it's beautiful,
it's different and um,
but I think that it still gets back to
some of the same elemental issues,
you know,
talking about the.
Yeah,
I mean how do you manage risk in your
life and what's worth it and how do you
choose it's,
it's a smart move to for company to just
kinda like very the kind of input that
gets to the,
the,
the employees like give them something
that's kind of spectacular and
interesting and you know really well now
when you look at the future,
do you,
do you have a map of what you would like
to be doing?
Do you,
are you just sort of enjoying your
experience here or do,
do you have grand plans?
I don't really have grand plans.
I mean I've never really had a grand
plan.
It's always been that I love climbing.
I want to do it well.
I want to push myself and I think that's
kind of my grand plan.
I mean I'm a,
I'm still trying to be a better climber.
I'm still trying to grow the foundation,
do something more significant through
it.
I'm actually hired a full time executive
director this year,
this woman who's running a me,
which is kind of awesome.
So we're actually sort of ramping it all
up a little bit.
That was slightly in response to the
film because I sort of figured that,
you know,
this is like a moment that I should try
to take advantage of and use it to do
something more positive and so,
so that's sort of exciting for me and
um,
it's definitely not a grand plan,
but it's,
you know,
it's just sort of all incremental
incremental progress.
So when you're doing all these climbs,
you have a lot of time when you're,
it takes time to do these things.
So was this,
when you start thinking about these
ideas about thinking about like how much
you enjoy being out here in nature and
what I'm caring about the environment
for sure.
Yeah,
I mean I spend most of my time in the
most beautiful places on earth.
I mean,
spending most of my time in national
parks and public lands in general.
And so I'm in all these beautiful places
and it's like,
yeah,
I mean I care about them.
I went to,
you know,
if I have a family someday,
I want to be able to take my kids to the
same places and have them appreciate the
land in the same way.
I mean,
yeah,
so like you send of the last five years
for can the entire forest is basically
died from pine beetles,
will all the pine trees have basically
died because pine beetles and so like
just in the last five years,
let's say the Yosemite Valley floor has
sort of transformed from like a dense
pine forest to sort of this open oak
forest.
It's like totally different character
because all the pine trees have died and
then they've been cutting them all down
to reduce fuel load.
So they're basically logging trucks with
pine trees,
leaving the park nonstop,
which you know,
which I'm,
which I totally support.
I'm not like anti logging the dead trees
because like you may as well use them if
they're already dead.
And I definitely don't want to see so
many value all burst into flames.
So it makes sense,
but at the same time,
I mean,
you know,
that's a real,
that's a very direct result of climate.
Gender mean it's 10 years of drought in
California combined with,
with shorter winters.
It's like just have these beetles
decimating the entire forest and I don't
know,
I mean that's,
that sucks,
you know,
like I don't,
I don't want to see the whole forest die
and it's not an invasive beetle or is it
a beetle invasive invasive in that,
uh,
I don't know specifically with you
seminar,
I could be wrong about this,
but with a lot of the pine beetle
problems in,
in Colorado,
it has more to do with shorter winter
and warmer temperatures because normally
the larva would die through the winter.
They would freeze.
Um,
but you know,
basically they're not freezing in to the
same extent.
And so the population explodes and then
you wind up with all the trees dying
while we were there.
And we were in big bear a few years back
when they were having a real issue with
it and they were having real significant
fire scares young.
It was,
it was nerve wracking.
No,
I mean you,
somebody who was like on fire for most
of the summer.
It was this crazy for the whole southern
part of the park was like burning for
months and that's,
you know,
I mean fire is a natural part of the
ecosystem and that,
you know,
to some extent your life that's normal,
but it's like it's not normal right now
because the fuel load is so high.
It's like so dry.
It's just,
it's too much,
you know,
and I just would love for my kids
someday to be able to appreciate the
park the way I have for so long and I
just don't want to see you don't burn.
Yeah.
When I was,
when we were in big bear,
that's my feeling.
It was,
it was,
it was sad that you're seeing something
that was probably this rich green,
lush forest that's now really weird gray
and drive.
But it was also like you're around
kindling,
like you're basically in a big stack of
dry wood before it gets lit on fire and
you're surrounded by it and there's
enough.
It hits up there.
It's,
I mean I've,
we've been evacuated where I live
several times,
twice,
actually come close a couple of other
times and it's,
it's terrifying because southern
California when it goes,
it goes and there's just no stopping it.
No,
I mean that's.
Yeah,
no,
that's.
I mean that's like,
yeah,
this is why I'm like,
this is why we transitioned to solar
sooner,
you know,
because it's like if it helps at all
with these kinds of issues,
then it's like,
worth,
worth the effort,
you know,
it's going to happen anyway.
It's like you may as well just do it
now,
so I just think that you were doing an
Antarctica,
you're filming something there as well.
Do you do a lot of that now?
I'm well for a trip like that for an
expedition.
I mean that was the north face
expedition and so that's where they get
a lot of their brand content and so it
makes sense to film a trip like that and
we were somewhere where the nobody ever
goes.
We were doing first a sense of peaks,
ended up never been climbed so it kind
of makes sense to document that to some
extent.
But in general I think I try to balance
my just pure climbing with filming.
That's what I was going to ask you.
Like you don't want to get,
you don't want to film all the timing,
everything that's on your head every
week.
Now that stuff drives me crazy.
I'm not into that.
But when you're in the most beautiful
place,
sometimes it makes sense.
Well where's something,
especially for someone like north face,
I mean their whole company is about
really exploration.
Yeah.
When,
when you are in that sort of situation
where you're filming these things,
like is it difficult to be,
to act normal,
to be,
to,
to be yourself?
We're not refuse if you saw free solar,
you know,
that I only have one mode and that's
just,
that's just me.
Um,
which I mean when,
when I see the film,
a lot of them like,
oh,
maybe I need to censor myself a little
more.
Like maybe think there should be a
little more thoughtful about what I say,
but,
but um,
no,
I mean I'm pretty much always,
I just,
I just do.
Me and the people are filming or not.
They just get.
I mean,
I'm more mindful of profanity and a few
things like that.
If I know that I'm being filmed right
now,
I'm being watched.
Then I try to be slightly more
respectful,
especially if I see kids in an audience
that definitely try not to curse.
But um,
but overall I'm like,
no,
I just,
I just always stay in my mind,
you know.
Well,
that's what I was talking about earlier
when I was asking the difference between
you when you're being your,
your love of this is your love of nature
and of being in these beautiful national
forests and public lands and
experiencing these amazing environments.
But then sometimes that gets sort of
perverted when you filming everything
and you've got people just.
Everything becomes this sort of
presentation and everything becomes
professional.
And I mean I think that's the risk with
filming.
I think with Free Solo.
I think they did an amazing job of,
of maintaining the character,
you know,
the nuance.
Not perverting it in any way.
No,
I think so too.
I think it was amazing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think,
uh,
I think they did a really good job of
that,
like,
and it's still,
it's still sort of understated,
you know,
even though it's like this spectacular
feat,
it's still sort of subdued and its own
way.
It's just sort of lays it out
beautifully.
Let's you just sort of judge for
yourself and just,
well,
you know,
it's impossible to be anything but
spectacular so you don't really have to
dress it up.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
Well that's the beauty of filming
anything in Yosemite is that it's just,
I mean it's,
it's honestly just one of the most
beautiful places on earth would be like
putting a pretty dress on a Ferrari or
like leave it alone.
It's done.
You've already got it.
Have you ever thought about doing some
like live journal from the field or some
sort of a podcast or something along
those lines?
Um,
no,
I mean,
should I.
yeah,
that sounds,
that sounds like too much work.
A podcast would be easy.
I don't know,
but you have to be able to interview
people proper way.
No,
you don't.
you don't think.
My friend bill burr has a podcast where
he just talks.
He does a fucking great,
but he's a comedian.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
With Monday morning podcast,
but you just sitting down.
I mean you could go off notes,
you could go off of and just.
I think people would love that if you
just never thought about it.
I mean in some ways I do have strong
opinions about a lot of things,
like if I just ranted about
environmental issues and similar things
that I care about,
that actually would be kind of fun,
but you'd have a significant impact to
especially have such a large platform
now.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
I'll consider it.
That's the first time that anyone's ever
mentioned.
I'm sort of like,
I could think about that.
I'm notorious for trying to talk people
into podcast,
but I really think in your case you'd be
a great idea.
I mean,
you really feel like.
I tell everyone to do it,
but you should really do it well.
People get mad
at me.
You keep telling people to do it,
but I think you,
if you had a portable unit,
like a fricking players,
something you can just record a phone.
Really?
Oh yeah.
A recording on your phone.
It's very easy.
Um,
you could,
I mean we've done a bunch of them were
just the voice notes from the phone just
talking to the voice notes from the
phone and you can make a podcast off
that and it's really easy to upload.
But just saving.
Maybe that's my future.
Sitting in your van,
you know,
afterwards and just talking about things
you're working on with your foundation,
talking about spectacular moments during
climbs where you're,
you're seeing things and you know,
talking about what it's been like doing
this tour for free.
Yeah.
No,
I'm like,
I'll,
I'll think about it.
I mean that's interesting.
I understand where to put it out there.
I mean,
I think it's a great idea,
man.
Huh?
You consider to get it out or send me a
little MP.
Three recorder.
We can definitely do that,
but we could also help you like pro.
I can promote it for you,
put it on twitter,
let people,
we'll see if uh,
if I ever actually do anything like
that.
But um,
but no,
it's an interesting idea.
I mean it's an interesting way to like
share,
share ideas better.
Well,
well the reason why I'm saying this just
because you have this very specific,
very unusual life and you also have all
these ideas about the environment and
have all these ideas about using it for
positive reasons and altruistic,
hoping to freaking make the world a
better place and having,
making an impact with your foundation.
I really think it could look the best
thing with your foundation would be to
make,
make it expose to more people and it
would most certainly do that.
Yeah.
I'll talk to my executive director about
that too.
I mean that would be an interesting way
to at least share the ideas that I care
about.
Yeah,
exactly.
The idea of just sitting in a recording,
I'm like,
oh yeah,
Kinda cool.
You know,
like,
like you at the base of a mountain just
talking about this and climbing and your
personal thoughts in that
could be Douchey,
but it'd have to be well done.
You'd have to be a Douche bag for it to
be douchey.
Well that's the danger.
That's the danger.
You just never.
I mean,
nobody thinks that they're the Douche,
you know,
you think you'd become a Douche or you
just never know.
You never know when you're like,
I'm just gonna record monologues of me
rambling about ideas.
That's when you start to trend towards
do sheena's perhaps.
Well,
it's a slippery slope.
You could always review it or have your
girlfriend review it.
Yeah,
that's.
You don't have to do it live.
Just,
you know.
And then she could say,
okay,
that part we use rant and rave about
diesel might want to.
No,
I mean why or maybe not.
Yeah.
No,
I feel strongly about.
I'll rant and rave about diesel forever.
That's just not bros.
Yeah man.
Imagine when electric trucks,
You know,
like long haul trucking or mike.
Oh well tesla's already on there.
On the ball with that.
Yeah.
We'll hopefully,
I kind of don't care who comes market
first,
that stuff.
I just want somebody to start selling a
lot of them.
She was lIke,
I just wanted the change to happen
quickly.
It doesn't matter who does it or how.
It's like,
it just needs to happen.
You've got a very significant voice
right now.
I really think that you could make a big
impact with a lot of people.
And the thing about these impacts,
it's sorta like the butterfly effect,
right?
It's like you never know what it
actually changes.
I agree with how many people are going
to hear you just from this podcast and
the things you're saying about solar and
about and people thinking about like,
yeah,
maybe,
maybe I can do something and then boom,
it just makes these little incremental
steps and then they carry on momentum
and you never know.
Well that's the,
that's the positive way of looking at
it,
you know,
cool to like notes from wherever you are
just.
I mean he doesn't,
you don't have to have.
The beautiful thing is too,
it doesn't have to have any kind of
structure.
You don't have to have any time.
You can do one for 15 minutes if you
want and people will listen to it.
You could do it for an hour,
know that that might be a little micro
hits like little rambles for sure.
Do it as long as you want,
and it looked.
Like I said,
the beautiful thing about things like
this is that there's no.
There's no real structure to it where
you have to do something totally.
Totally.
You just decide in a lot of ways,
that's the nature of climbing to where
you never have to do anything.
You just find what inspires you.
You work towards it,
you do it when you're excited about it.
I'm totally into that kind of thing
because it's actually,
that's.
I've always cry,
contrast to cliMbing from other
mainstream sports like that because with
climbing,
it's like the objective is always there.
YOu're always inspired by it.
You do it whenever you're ready as
opposed to having to perform on the
right day at the right time.
You know,
it's like,
I love that lifesTyle where you're like,
you know,
today is my day,
or today's not my day,
just like maybe like leading up to you
free soloing el cap.
If there was sort of a documented audio
journal while I watch the film,
this is,
you're just wetting their appetite.
I mean it's a beautiful film.
It's fantastic,
but there's people like to see more and
more stuff.
Interesting and it's entirely up to you
what you want to share.
Don't want to share it.
Especially if yOu do it this way.
You don't have an executive producer,
you don't have directors,
you know,
totally would.
That.
I definitely couldn't handle too much.
Just you just,
you just talking about stuff and your
specific vision of the things that you'd
like to talk about and your,
your specific message because that's one
of the things that people really,
really enjoy about something like a
podcast is that they know there's no one
telling you what to say or what to do
that,
you know,
following your heart,
sitting in his van,
you know,
drinking a cup of tea just with the
iphone talking.
It's hard to imagine people would find
that.
Understand what I'm telling You.
Oh,
I'm really surprised.
I bet though.
Tell him jamie people,
Would it be listening to it people to
you for sure.
Oh no.
I appreciate that,
but I'm slightly worried I'm going to
be.
I'm going to miss my plane.
Okay.
Yeah,
we gotta get you outta here.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for being here.
I really appreciate
it.
Excellent.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's fun to chat again because I
remember last time I was on the show
with,
it was a full experience for him.
It's one of the first time that I'd done
anything like that and it was like,
It was pretty mega.
I was like,
whoa,
I have no idea what I'm doing.
This is so much.
And like now I feel so much more
comfortable and fun to chat.
It was awesome.
It was great.
It was really great to see what I'm
saying.
It feels like coming of age to come back
and shouted.
Yeah,
it's really nice.
Beautiful.
Alright,
cool.
I appreciate it.
Thanks alex.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
that's what I remember last time.